3 and 10 are like terms.
Both of them are constants.
They have no variables.
Note that constants like 3 and
10 can be considered like terms.
6x and 6y are not like terms.
The variables that they
have are different.
5x cubed and 7x cubed are like pairs.
They share the variable, x cubed.
Note that x is raised to
the 3rd power for both terms.
8ab and 9ab are also like terms.
They both share both variables a and b.
7a squared b and
7ab squared are not like terms.
Even though they both have both a and b,
a and b are raised to different powers.
Here, a is raised to the 2nd power and
b is raised to the 1st power.
Here, a is raised to the 1st power and
b is raised to the 2nd power.
So, they're not like terms.